the vaccine program has exceeded
expectations but it is about to become
the victim of its own success the reason
is what we might call the second dose
debt now this chart shows where we are
and where the government wants to get to
as of yesterday almost 26 million people
had received a first dose that's the
blue lines
and the lower yellow line shows almost 2
million people have had a second dose
the target is for the 32 million people
in the top
nine priority groups to have had their
first dose by the 15th of april
but the real date that's been driving
the program is the 29th
of march that's 12 weeks from when the
rollout began in earnest when the
astrazeneca jab
joined the pfizer jab in circulation and
12 weeks
is when second doses become due as of
today the clock is ticking
for 23.9 million people in need of that
second jab
and that's why the delay to more than
five million doses couldn't have come
at a worse time just as the program
needs to accelerate
the nhs has had to effectively pause
first doses
in april now this chart shows how the
first
dose boom becomes a second dose
debt now the blue bars here are the
first doses that were delivered
since january now from april they become
second doses that need to be delivered
we've used the current seven day rolling
average of more than 450 000 doses to
show what it looks like which is why
the line flattens off you can see there
are no first doses
at all in april where matt hancock says
12 million
second shots will be prioritized but
even so based on
current supply the second doses have
caught up the debt
has been paid by the first week in june
now this does mean everyone under 50 is
going to have to wait a little longer
than they hope for a shirt first shot
but based on current supply the program
is still
on track here you can see our projection
based on
current supply levels and you see the
flattening off there
in april when there are no first doses
but on this model
every adult still gets a first shot by
july the 18th
that's nearly two weeks ahead of target
and look second doses
have reached 31 million that's almost
everyone in the most vulnerable groups
and that could be everyone having had a
second dose by mid-september
if this rate continues now these are
just
projections and it's clear this delay
has cost the government some of its
headroom
and further hitches will have
consequences
but for now the vaccine program is still
on course for a remarkable success